c3po le personnage de monopoly et
pikachu il ya au moins l'un de ces trois
exemples sur lequel rien ne vous choque
eh bien vous avez tort vous pouvez
vérifier vous-même c3po à une jambe en
argent monsieur monopoly n'a jamais lu
de monocle et pikachu n'a jamais eu de
queue noire alors bon souvenir vous ont
joué des tours on va même pas vos
souvenirs et nos souvenirs de manière
collective
est ce qu'il est possible qu'on soit
tous sont venus de quelque chose de faux
au pont c'est presque comme si on avait
été à un moment dans une autre réalité
parce que parfois
en 2010 fiona broom une américaine
découvre un phénomène étrange pendant
une conférence
elle se rend compte que la plupart des
participants croyait comme elle que
nelson mandela était mort durant son
emprisonnement en 1981 alors qu'il
pourra bien plus tard en 2013
elle enferme les faits demande est là et
elle se rend compte que cela touche
d'autres histoires comme le fait qu'on
pense que le héros de la place tiananmen
se serait fait écraser par le tank suite
à son opposition ou que mère teresa se
serait fait canonisé dans les années 90
alors que cela s'est passé en 2016 une
confusion de la mémoire collective
quand nous sommes tous convaincus de
partager un souvenir en commun alors
qu'il n'existe pas ou qu'il est des
formes
bon ça peut faire sourire dit comme ça
mais il faut se dire que bon nombre de
personnes qui soutiennent ces faits
fossé pense détenir la vérité
ils pensent que c'est carrément une
déformation de la réalité dont on est
tous victimes avec des souvenirs
alternatif causés par l'existence de
deux réalités à un moment donné dans une
seule réalité devrait été superposées
ça vous dit quelque chose le chercheur
odinga est si vous n'êtes pas sûr de ce
que c'est je vous conseille de regarder
cette vidéo
lorsque vous aurez fini celle ci ok
c'est ce chat qui est à la fois mort est
à la fois vivant un des deux étages
superposés pour young everett physicien
américain
il ya alors deux mondes parallèles l'un
ou le chat est vivant et l'autre où il
est mort chaque événement que nous
rencontrons à n'importe quelle échelle
ne connais pas un seul résultat mais une
bifurcation entre deux ou plusieurs
résultats possibles et les réalités
altérée par les autres résultats
vivre est alors en parallèle de la nôtre
1 il faut pas imaginer que ces mondes
parallèles qui surgissent soit de la
substance de la nouvelle matière mais
sont plutôt des nouvelles structures
mais est ce que tout ça est vraiment lié
au fait que dark vador n'a jamais
prononcé la phrase luke je suis ton père
mais non
le mot il n'est jamais mentionnée dans
un film star wars comics ne s'écrit pas
au n y x mais bien au n os x ou que les
libyens de retour vers le futur ne
conduisent pas ce type de véhicule mais
un van volkswagen pas vraiment notre
cerveau n'est pas une machine
infaillible capable de mémoriser manière
intactes toutes les informations
certains souvenirs se transforme ou
s'effacent avec le temps et c'est normal
mais surtout nos représentations
mentales peuvent être remises en
question sous l'effet groupe
combien de fois vous est il arrivé vous
qu'au moins de remettre en question aux
certitudes
parce que trois quatre cinq personnes
soutiennent fermement le contraire est
aussi un phénomène de dissonance
cognitive qui peut s'observer parfois ça
nous arrive de nous retrouver dans un
état très désagréable lorsque quelqu'un
confronte une information incompatible
avec nos croyances
on va souvent choisir de renforcer de
croyance et ne pas laisser place à la
critique
mais ces troubles de la mémoire ne
concerne pas que des éléments culturels
c'est faux souvenirs peuvent avoir des
conséquences beaucoup plus graves chez
l'être humain
sting titus et un américain de 31 ans
qui rentrait un soir du restaurant en
compagnie de sa jeune épouse quand une
voiture de police les a arrêtés sur la
route la hauteur de titus ressemblait un
peu à la voiture d'un agresseur sexuel
qui avait violé une auto stoppeuse un
peu plus tôt dans la journée
et pas de chance pour lui si tu se
ressemblaient également un peu à cet
homme les policiers l'ont pris en photo
mais le cliché au milieu de ceux
d'autres personnes et les ont présentées
à la victime en voyant le portrait titus
la victime a déclaré c'est lui qui
ressemble plus le procès s'ouvre et
titus se retrouve sur le banc des
accusés face à lui la victime qui
déclare je suis absolument sûr que c'est
cet homme
titus est alors jugé coupable est envoyé
directement en prison évidemment il n'a
cessé de dire en vain qu'il était
innocent il a supplié les juges de
libérer sans grand succès il a néanmoins
pu raconter son histoire un journaliste
d'investigation qui a pu mener une
enquête et trouvé le vrai coupable
déjà soupçonné d'une cinquantaine de
viol le véritable agresseur est alors
emprisonné et titus libéré par
l'histoire aurait pu s'arrêter là
laissant au mieux un gros traumatisme
attitude mais malheureusement l'homme
fut considérablement marqué par cette
affaire qui lui a fait perdre son
travail et l'intégralité de ses
économies et l'a porté plainte contre la
police pour tenir justice quelques jours
du procès il s'est réveillé plié en deux
par la douleur et suping crises
cardiaques mortels liés au stress
mais ce n'est pas un cas isolé dans le
cadre d'un projet aux états unis une
étude a été menée sur le cas de 300
prisonniers à tort pour effectuer cinq
dix vingt ans de prison pour des crimes
qu'ils n'avaient pas commis un des tests
adn ayant prouvé qu'ils étaient bien
innocente et trois quarts des 300
innocent condamné l'ont été à cause
d'une mémoire défaillante des témoins
oculaires à cause d'un faux souvenirs
mais le cas titus a servi une
psychologue cognitif américaine
spécialisée dans la mémoire humaine qui
a pu travailler dessus
c'est elisabeth lofthus à son objectif
c'est de comprendre pourquoi notre
cerveau retient des souvenirs fossé est
selon elle notre mémoire d'un registre
pas tout comme un magnétoscope mais
fonctionne plutôt comme une page
wikipédia on peut changer les
informations qui la composent mais les
autres le peuvent aussi
on appelle ça la mémoire constructive et
elle a mis en place plusieurs études
pour démontrer ce phénomène dans l'une
d'entre elles une simulation d'accidents
de route a été montré à des gens et un
premier groupe qui devait répondre à la
question à quelle vitesse aller les
voitures lors de l'impact
et un second groupe à la question à
quelle vitesse elle et les voitures lors
du choc
eh bien les gens du second groupe trouvé
que les voitures allaient plus vite
parce que le mot choc avait construit un
souvenir plus violent dans leur mémoire
y en a même certains qui parlait de
morceaux de verre sur le lieu de
l'accident alors qu'elle n'a jamais leur
mémoire a été formaté par l'angle des
questions posées et des mots employés
une autre étude mise en place par
l'équipe d'elisabeth concerne les
militaires et des soldats qui ont été
interrogés manière agressive et
physiquement violente pendant 30 minutes
et à la fin de l'interrogatoire et
devait identifier la personne qui venait
de leur faire passer un mauvais quart
d'heure
enfin deux mauvais quart d'heure dieu
parce que c'est 30 minutes lors de leur
réflexion on leur donne des suggestions
qui insinuait que c'était une personne
différente du sel qu'ils s'apprêtaient à
choisir et à beaucoup de cobayes qui
soit et c'est alors la mauvaise personne
en prenant même parfois à
l'interrogateur totalement différent
donc en associant de fausses
informations sur des expériences que des
gens ont vécu on peut déformer échanger
leurs souvenirs
elisabeth s est pas arrêté là elle a
dénoncé pas mal de psychothérapeute qui
utilisait un procédé de ce type là pour
soigner leurs patients un pour les aider
par exemple a surpassé un traumatisme
il leur a planté des faux souvenirs
parfois encore plus difficile à assumer
histoire de les délivrer de leurs
problèmes de base 1 et on observait du
coût des quatre patients qui sortait
thérapie avec un problème différent de
celui avec lequel il était rentré
mais condamne pas la mémoire
constructive comme un phénomène purement
néfastes même si de fortes qu'elles sont
et ils se posent tout dépend pour elle
des souvenirs que l'on souhaite moduler
et dans quel but je vous laisse vous
faire votre propre opinion là dessus
j'espère que l'effet mandela est
maintenant clair pour vous qui ne vous a
pas trop traumatisés parce que c'est
quand même dingue de réaliser d'un coup
que l'image qu'on se fait d'un souvenir
ou de quelqu'un ou d'une chose puisse
être totalement différente comme ça
d'une seconde à l'autre
n'hésitez pas à partager vos effets
mandela dans les commentaires la plupart
des exemples disponibles sur internet
sont américains tuent c'est cool de voir
des exemples directement liée à la
culture française si ce n'est pas déjà
fait n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la
chaîne pour pas rater les futurs vidéo
il y en a au moins une par semaine
donc c'est cool merci à tous ceux qui
contribuent sur le tipi c'est grâce à
vous que j'ai pu avoir des lumières trop
cool qui donne une telle qualité d'image
donc merci beaucoup plus en voix du love
et de l'api ce retour ciao